jacques mézard le président du groupe
rdse au sénat est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous donc pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec une agence france
presse
représenter ce soir par jean louis
prévost perrine tarneaud nous rejoindra
bien sûr en fin d'émission pour évoquer
notamment l'un des grands combats des
radicaux jacques mézard la laïcité quand
on débat à nouveau aujourd'hui
régulièrement mais avant d'évoquer
notamment la situation en grèce le vote
aujourd'hui de la loi macron ultime
recours donc à l'article 49-3 par manuel
valls qui affirme que c'est un coup de
jeune pour l'économie est ce que vous
partager son enthousiasme je crois que
c'est d'abord un message pense pas
qu'ils aient des mesures qui vont
révolutionner le fonctionnement de la
vie économique du pays mais c'est
clairement un message politique adressé
non seulement aux élus à la majorité
présidentielle mais à l'ensemble des
français
la loi macro quel message message qu'il
est nécessaire de de libéraliser de
donner plus de liberté aux fonctions au
fonctionnement de notre économie
je crois que c'est le message qui a été
d'ailleurs assez entendu au sénat mais
qu'est ce que traduit suffisamment dans
les faits concrètement non seulement vos
non non non parce que notre pays a
besoin d'avoir moins de contraintes
moins de contraintes ce n'est pas
fragilisé
ceux qui sont les plus fragiles
ce n'est pas à enlever des droits aux
salariés mais c'est permettre à
l'économie de travailler dans de
meilleures conditions est ce que vous
rejoignez par exemple l'opposition de
droite jacques mézard qui considère qui
est effectivement il manque dans ce
texte des mesures pour desserrer marché
du travail par exemple
oui je l' ai d'ailleurs dit mais je
crois qu'il faut être très prudent parce
que notre pays est quand même dans une
situation où faire bouger les choses ce
niveau là et est très difficile quel que
soit le gouvernement et je dis que nous
avons besoin d'eux
moins de contraintes de moins de normes
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
laisser faire tout et n'importe quoi à
ceux qui ont pouvoir et en particulier
le pouvoir économique mais on voit bien
quand on parle à des chefs d'entreprises
de petite entreprise de moyennes
entreprises sur le terrain qu'ils n'en
peuvent plus d'être étouffée par trop de
contraintes administratives et cela les
empêche atrocités c'est le code du
travail dans vous parlait il ya pas que
le code du travail allemand il y a le
code du travail il ya l'environnement il
ya tout un tas de contraintes dans tous
les secteurs et avec la meilleure
volonté du monde
les parlementaires en rajoute souvent
nous vivons et là nous avons aussi à
prendre conscience du fait qu'il faut
faire moins de loi pour mieux les
appliquer alors que les entreprises ils
le disent les deux mesures effet le plus
immédiat souligne encore manuel valls et
le travail le dimanche et l'ouverture de
lignes d'autocars parce que pour les
approuver et qu'est ce que vous en
espérez vous coûte
nous n'avons pas considérer
majoritairement dans ce groupe que la
question du travail le dimanche était
quelque chose qui allait révolutionner
d'autant qu'il ya beaucoup de français
déjà qui travaillent le dimanche
et que se battent pour savoir si les
commerces vont pouvoir ouvrir un plus de
dimanche n'est quand même pas une
révolution idéologique lignes d'autocars
c'est un autre dossier parce que il faut
que nous considérions que dans
particulier dans les territoires ruraux
que je représente souvent et en
particulier il ya une crainte il ya une
crainte c'est que ce message ce soit on
ferme les lignes de train on sait bien
que c'est difficile de faire fonctionner
arrivera vous avez entendu le
gouvernement se réserve cette
possibilité mais après les régionales
oyo je ne doutais pas un de l'objectif
final mais là il faudrait il faut être
très prudent ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
rien bouger mais ça veut dire que il
faut que nous conservions un certain
nombre de lignes ferroviaires qui sont
indispensables sur nos techniques même
si elles sont déficitaires et utilisé
par très peu de voyageurs avec des rames
à moitié vide ou aux trois quarts vide
jacques mézard ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut les conserver tout ça veut dire que
dans un pays si on n'a pas une politique
d'aménagement du territoire une
politique qui permet justement 20 dans
certains territoires et dans certains
cas de conserver un certain nombre de
moyens de transport ou de vie qui sont
déficitaires et vient dans ce cas là il
vaut mieux dire à ceux qui vivent des
ménages est bon alors que là aussi il
faut du bon sens il faut de l'équilibré
dernier point sur la loi macron abords
du passage en force avec l'article 49-3
qu'est ce que ça révèle selon vous de
l'état du ps et de la majorité à
laquelle vous appartenez
oui même si je suis souvent critique ça
révèle très simplement que les lignes de
fracture fondamentale traverse les deux
partis principaux le parti socialiste et
les républicains et qu'on voit bien que
gouverner dans ces conditions là et
c'est un des problèmes de la vème
république qui à mon avis et vit une
crise c'est extrêmement difficile parce
que le gouvernement en place est obligé
de tenir compte de positions là deux
parlementaires qui sont manifestement
pas en phase avec le gouvernement alors
qu'ils sont les élus de ce parti
dominant quelle conséquence vous en
tirer pour l'avenir
pour l'avenir je pense que je souhaite
pour la re distribution des cartes
politiques
je le souhaite vivement parc indique
qu'il vaut mieux que ceux qui ont des
conceptions assez proches sur des
problèmes fondamentaux que ce soit la
construction de l'europe que ce soit
l'économie
que ce soit les institutions travaillent
ensemble plutôt que d'être opposé par le
système alors revenu d'enseignement
radical de gauche vous seriez prêt à
faire alliance avec qui dans ce contexte
là que cette série vous définissez il
s'agit pas de donner des noms et non
parce que ça n'a pas ça n'a pas de sens
de donner non je crois que ça veut dire
très simplement qu'il faut voir c'est
dans ce parti par exemple écouter nom de
parti il ya une bonne partie du parti
socialiste il ya les radicaux de gauche
il peut y avoir des centristes il peut y
avoir des républicains je moi je crois
que la france est dans une telle
situation
aujourd'hui comme nombre de pays
qu'il faut essayer de surmonter dans
certains cas des clivages qui sont
artificiels c'est pas facile à dire
c'est pas facile à assumer
parce que la tranquillité des deux
grands partis c'est de continuer à être
l'un après l'autre au gouvernement mais
aujourd'hui le système de l'élection
présidentielle le quinquennat que j'ai
combattu abouti malheureusement à une
situation politique qui n'est pas très
heureuse et qui favorise la montée des
extrêmes d'accord alors justement vous
avez cité l'europe comme ligne de
fracture au sein des deux grands partis
que vous avez cité le parti socialiste
et puis les républicains alors qu'on
attend donc les réformes les
contreparties précise alexis tsipras ça
une nouvelle aide européenne à la grèce
quel regard est ce que vous vous portez
sur ce premier ministre grec qui qui
joue avec les nerfs de ses partenaires
et créanciers
je pense qu'il y à une surmédiatisation
ce que l'on a vu dimanche soir avec des
chaînes en continu n'arrêtant pas de
parler de du premier ministre grec de ce
qu'il avait fait avant c'était normal
c'était l'avènement de la soirée vous
considérez que ils ont célébré les
médias ont célébré avec ces deux cépages
je considère que on donne à cet
événement un poids qui dans l'avenir je
le pense démontrera que c'est quand même
de la surmédiatisation
ceci étant on peut le comprendre
je crois aussi que le premier ministre
si price joue il joue parce qu'il a pris
des engagements avec ses concitoyens
qu'il se rend compte que ces engagements
sont extrêmement difficile à tenir et
que à la fois le référendum avait pour
but de rassurer ses concitoyens et de
les regrouper autour de lui sur les
thèmes qui lui sont chers mais en même
temps aussi
nous voyons aujourd'hui qu'il est obligé
mais il à ne faire des problèmes il faut
que je continue à chercher un compromis
avec quelqu'un qui joue t moi je ne
crois pas que l'on puisse faire tout et
n'importe quoi
je les dis hier dans la discussion
générale il faut de la solidarité mais à
condition qu'elle soit accompagnée de
fermeté nous ne pouvons pas accepter par
rapport à la grèce ce que l'on ne fait
pas vis-à-vis à d'autres pays je pense
au portugal qui règle
rubis sur l'ongle ses engagements
financiers et donc dans ces conditions
moi je crois que il y aura une sortie
positive non pas de l'euro mais qu'il y
aura une solution qui sera trouvée parce
que la grèce a plus à perdre à sortir de
l'euro la question de l'union européenne
ne se pose pas parce qu'ils sortiront
pas de l'union européenne
mais on a plus à perdre à sortir de
l'euro qu'à trouver à faire des
propositions raisonnables
on parle souvent de ce qui se passe en
grèce sur les retraites sur le fait que
le clergé ne payent pas l'impôt que les
armateurs my pas grand chose ils ont
manifestement un certain nombre de
propositions sérieuses à faire le la
moyenne médiane aujourd'hui les
retraites en grèce ces 900 euros comme
en allemagne et en france on est à 1200
euros
je n'entends pas beaucoup un de ceux qui
sont les zélateurs de monsieur si prince
en france se plaindre des retraites par
exemple dans le monde agricole en france
qui sont souvent au dessous de 700 euros
chacun assume des difficultés de cette
année les amateurs on les trouve
notamment aux extrêmes oui vous avez
clairement mais le gouvernement de
monsieur sy brasse il ya un représentant
d'un parti souverainiste très très à
droite
donc c'est la conjonction d'un certain
nombre de deux
deux partis qui représentent
effectivement des courants très
différents mais qui sont dans moyen de
rapprochement c'est le populisme
il ya aussi dans les bronches monsieur
sy brasse un certain nombre d'anciens
conseillers de gouvernement anciens qui
sont aujourd'hui décrié gouvernement
socialiste riz alors le couple
franco-allemand a été très exposé durant
cette crise
et vous vous écoutez jacques mézard on
se dit que vous pensez peut-être plus du
côté de l'intransigeance d'angela merkel
que de la volonté de conciliation
françois hollande est ce que je me
trompe
bon je crois je crois que les les deux
il est nécessaire vis-à-vis de la grèce
d'avoir un message de fermeté en disant
il ya des choses qui ne sont pas
acceptables il faut pas non plus les
victimes victimiser la grèce donc je
crois que le couple allemand
chacun joue le professionnel mans chacun
joue sa partition et les deux sont
attachés à la construction européenne
alors il la voit peut-être pas
exactement de la manière mais je crois
d'ailleurs que la complémentarité de ces
deux positions à condition qu'elles ne
s'opposent pas mais qu'elle soit
complémentaire est utile il faut faire
comprendre a été le cas je crois juste
un oui je crois qu'il faut faire
comprendre à la grèce qui a un seuil à
un niveau au delà duquel les autres pays
n'iront pas et je pense monsieur
peut-être optimiste que le gouvernement
grec sera obligé d'entendre ce message
en suivra ça dans les heures qui
viennent un mot sur un homme d'affaires
qui qui est fumante du parti radical de
gauche prg candidat que votre parti et
bernard tapie
jacques mézard rien ne l'arrête il veut
réclamer maintenant un milliard d'euros
à l'état plus les intérêts sur 20 ans
dans la sphère adidas est ce qu il a
raison de tenter le coup parce que je
suis étonné que vous ne posiez pas la
question sur le scandale de panama il ya
125 ans sur l'affairé stavisky avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
contrairement à vous je n'ai jamais eu
l'occasion de discuter avec monsieur
tapie il a été dans le parti radical de
gauche ici même il y a trois ou quatre
ans j'ai été interrogé sur un éventuel
mans à un éventuel retour
tapi dans le parti et j'ai dit que s'ils
y rentrer je partirai donc je n'ai pas
d'autres commentaires
donc un commentaire si on met de côté ce
son étiquette politique même ancien je
le fais je n'ai jamais en tout cas
accepter personnellement le mélange de
l'affairisme et de la politique
sd sans selon vous de sa part de
réclamer cette somme colossale sachant
qu'il avait déjà reçu ce chèque de plus
de 15 millions d'euros de bercy car rien
n'est descend dans le mélange de
l'affairisme et de la politique voilà
voilà c'est dit avec force
pas de mélange de politique et
d'affairisme à propos de bernard tapie
on poursuit cette émission jacques
mézard avec jean louis prévost de l'
agence france-presse
qui va nous rejoindre et nous allons
explorer le monde mystérieux et opaque
des zones ministre d autorité
administrative indépendante puisque vous
avez voulu une commission d' enquête sur
ces commissions qui coûte cher et dont
l'utilité reste à démontrer avant de
vous interroger donc premiers éléments
de compréhension et d'interrogations
avec faustine sa jeunesse vous
connaissez sans doute l'autorité des
marchés financiers le csa ou encore la
cnil mais connaissez-vous la fld où le
hcr es des autorités administratives
indépendantes comme celle ci il en
existe une quarantaine en france mais à
quoi servent tél c'est l'une des
questions que pose la commission d'
enquête sur ce sujet au sénat
créée en avril dernier à la demande des
radicaux de gauche le moment est
probablement venu de s'intéresser
enfin de se poser la question est ce que
il faut continuer à multiplier les hôtes
les autorités qu'est ce que ça veut dire
à la fois en termes de de la question
des finances publiques et qu'est ce que
ça veut dire aussi en terme de pouvoir
qui qui gouverne
objectif donc défricher cet amas
d'autorité en tout genre certaines
disposent de moyens financiers propres
certaines peuvent exercer des sanctions
la commission met donc des auditions
tous azimuts mais à chaque fois les
intéressés répondent la même chose
l'initiative des sénateurs est bonne
mais pas question a priori deux touchera
leur entité indispensable selon eux les
questions qui m'ont été posées n'était
nullement une remise en cause du rôle du
csa en tant qu autorité administrative
indépendante
ce débat nous a permis d'avoir un
échange et sur les fondements de
l'institution et sur son actualité
récente difficile de faire bouger les
lignes sur ce thème véritable serpent de
mer
en 2010 déjà un rapport parlementaire
épinglés ces autorités administratives
indépendantes
son auteur le député socialiste rené
dosière tout sur la tanche soumises à un
contrôle normes budgétaires qui
s'applique d'administration ce qui n'est
pas le cas avant mais si certaines de
ces recommandations ont été prises en
compte
cela reste encore très insuffisant à son
goût il y a un certain nombre
d'autorités qui n'ont plus d'utilité qui
pourraient disparaître
je crois qu'il faut que les parlements
regarde de beaucoup plus près le
fonctionnement l'activité de ses
autorités indépendantes pour pouvoir
à ce moment-là modifier les règles voire
faire disparaître ou regroupées celles
qui ont besoin de se retrouver avec
d'autres davantage de contrôle par le
parlement lui-même une piste qui
pourrait être reprise par les sénateurs
reste à savoir si ce nouveau rapport
sera suivie d'effet
alors on envie d'en savoir plus sur ces
administrations en face et ses
organismes avec vous jean louis prévost
vos questions à jacques mézard qui
sont-elles lesquels peut-il éliminé
prioritairement en somme ce mézard
ces fameuses autorités administratives
indépendantes alors à votre avis est-ce
qu'elles sont aussi trop nombreuses
lesquels vous voudriez supprimer ou non
n'est pas la liste des suppressions
j'évolue qu'il y ait une commission d'
enquête du sénat pour que nous puissions
faire véritablement le point sur ces
autorités administratives indépendantes
aujourd'hui il y en a 40 de la première
a été créée en 1979 ça fait donc
pratiquement une par an et si ça
continue on n'aura plus assez de
conseillers d'état de conseiller à la
cour des comptes ou à la cour de
cassation pour remplir les collèges de
ces autorités administratives
indépendantes parce qu'il ya quand même
souvent les mêmes personnes ou en tout
cas le même type de personne qui y
siègent
quarante deux c'est beaucoup c'est
l'expression du délitement du pouvoir de
l'état et moi on républicain assez
jacobins je le concède
je considère que ce n'est pas une bonne
chose est que là dedans il ya de tout
comme autorité administrative
indépendante avec des moyens de
fonctionnement extrêmement différent des
moyens financiers extrêmement différent
et certaines qui ont pris au cours de
ces dernières années un pouvoir
considérable en voit aujourd'hui les
problèmes du csa je ne reviendrai pas là
dessus en aura l'occasion d'y revenir
d'ici le mois de septembre
l'autorité de la concurrence à laquelle
la loi macron donne encore plus de
pouvoir de son président nous a expliqué
il veut plus de moyens que de pouvoir
lui aussi failli là il a mis un milliard
d' euros damende qui peut en faire
autant en france est pas mal et des
consommateurs c'est contre les ententes
entre les oui mais oui c'est sûr dit il
siège dans ces autorités administratives
dite indépendante et c'est ça c'est une
question de fond est alors vous pensez
que ce sont des représentants des
industries ou des distributions qui
siègent là
autorités de la concurrence qui devrait
écouter vous lirez pas ce que je vais
pas aujourd'hui déflorer les conclusions
d'un rapport qui est en cours mais il
suffit de voir qui siègent dans les
collèges pour se poser un certain nombre
de questions il ya des autorités
administratives indépendantes qui sont
utiles et dont le statut ne peut pas
être ne doit pas être remise en cause je
pense au défenseur des droits
je pense à la cnil ensuite les regroupe
les regroupements cet autre chose mais
nous ne disons pas qu'il faut supprimer
toutes les autorités administratives
indépendantes
nous disons il y en a trop on en crée en
moyenne une par an c'est vraiment le
délitement du pouvoir de l'état et dans
la composition des collèges de ces
autorités administratives indépendantes
on voit quand même pratiquement toujours
mais c'est le législateur qui en a
décidé donc nous sommes responsables les
moteurs on voit des conseillers d'état
on voit des conseillers des membres de
la cour des comptes on voit un des
membres de la cour de cassation et des
quelques parlementaires
c'est très variable soutient il il y en
a apparemment a priori personnalités
éminentes met tout sur le même moule bon
et avec la même origine je ne dis pas
qu'il ya partout la promotion voltaire
de l'ena maillard ya quand même pas mal
vous parlez des rémunérations il ya de
tout dire il y en a qui font ce travail
pratiquement bénévolement
ça dépend des autorités administratives
indépendantes et il y en a qui ont des
revenus extrêmement important ceci étant
dans certains secteurs on vous dira
qu'il faut qu'ils aient des revenus
importants sinon ils peuvent pas les
trouver puisqu'il voudront pas venir
donc mais là dedans il y a en tout cas
un travail de fond à réaliser c'est
d'avoir un système d' autorité
administrative indépendante
reposant sur des bases identiques sur
des méthodes de fonctionnement et deux
contrôles identiques en tous cas si on
continue à en créer une par an on va
vraiment avoir de plus en plus de
problèmes
et alors qu'est ce que vous avez proposé
vous allez vous faire un rapport et ce
rapport ce rapport c'est le rapport
d'une commission
dungy une proposition de loi où je n'ai
pas l'habitude de travailler simplement
pour dans le but d'occuper un certain
nombre d'après-midi aux deux matinées de
parlementaires donc ce rapport il sera
suivi de propositions de loi que je
déposerai la suppression de certaines
oui mais le gars comme si je vous
soumets l'autorité de contrôle des
nuisances aéroportuaires vous dit on la
supprime celle là nous lui dirons nous
dit la crise ont accès aux documents
administratifs
la commission d'accès aux documents
administratifs on en a besoin alors
qu'elles soient regroupées qu'elles
soient regroupées peut-être avec le
défenseur des droits peut se concevoir
mais celle là on en a besoin
il y en a dont l'utilité quand même pose
pose question tout cela c'est nous avons
auditionné le notre ancien collègue le
doyen gélard qui a travaillé là dessus
et qui nous a dit moi je pense qu'il
faut en supprimer 80 % quelle est la
question
donc soit par suppression soit par
regroupements mais en tout cas y'a un
message fort du parlement qui était
exprimé c'est qu'on peut pas continuer à
en créer une par an et on ne peut pas
continuer à accepter que l'état se
désengage d'un certain nombre de
responsabilités en dix ans et plus -
c'est une autorité administrative
indépendante
on a vu pour le ca ca 20 que finalement
les conditions de désignation de la
présidente et de france télécom poser au
moins autant de problèmes que quand
c'était le précédent président de la
république qui désignèrent donc ça
laisse à réfléchir à ce que vous
détestez qu'on pourrait supprimer le csa
le pas dit ça non non on a beau on a
besoin d'une structure est un qui ne
suis pas être soumises à la suspicion on
a besoin effectivement d'une structure
dont on considère qu'elle est
véritablement indépendante et dont les
modes de fonctionnement et de
désignation ne donne pas lieu à ce qui
est en train de se passer
d'accord notamment des recours tout à
fait
mais ce que nous avons raté pas un peu
votre cible parce qu'à côté de ces
commis ces autorités administratives
indépendantes qui aussi toute une série
de commissions administratives là on a
par exemple un homme pèlerins qui vient
de créer un haut conseil de la
photographie monsieur prévost vous avez
parfaitement raison mais déjà auditionné
42 autorités administratives
indépendantes dans le cadre d'une
commission enquête c'est pas mal et moi
si vous voulez mon avis là dessus je
vous le donne et si vous me posez la
question c'est que vous le souhaitez mon
avis j'en ai assez je le dis constamment
de la création de haute autorité dans
tous les domaines 1
c'est absolument invraisemblable
inacceptable nous avons quand même
réussi ce matin à la commission mixte
paritaire sur la loi notre de réforme
territoriale a supprimé le haut quand le
projet de au conseil des territoires
mais il faut arrêter mais on a
l'impression aujourd'hui que chaque
ministre vos cheveux sont au conseil il
faut dire que quand on ensuite on y met
des représentants dedans on peut faire
plaisir à pas mal de gens mais c'est pas
comme ça qu'on peut faire avancer
l'administration française et les
intérieurs alors la loi notre justement
c'est une simplification administrative
là au niveau des collectivités
ovono il faut tout est à refaire il
faudra recommencer
je crois que les élus locaux en ont
assez de la mairie théorie de ces
réformes qui n'arrêtent pas parce que la
réforme c'est bien si c'est mieux
qu'avant mais en tout cas si c'est la
réforme en continu je peux vous dire que
les élus locaux
moi je cumule je suis fier que vu les à
une fonction parlementaire et une
présidence de communauté d'agglomération
je peux vous dire que les élus locaux la
réforme territoriale ils en ont jusque
là ils disent stop stop stop
maintenant il ya un an si elle n'est pas
parfaite il sera bien on sera bien
obligé dans l'avenir de corriger c'est
un certain nombre d'effets par exemple
est ce que vous vous êtes fait à la
fusion de l'auvergne de l'aed rhône
alpes donc je n'ordonne me suis pas fait
mais la loi est la loi
bon je ne me suis pas fait parce que
c'est absurde envers rap en arrière ça
vous savez
c'est vous qui le dites quand il y à des
décisions absurdes qui sont faites
il est quand même possible d'envisager
que dans l'avenir on modifiera certains
errements parce que vous m'expliquerez
comment on peut fonctionner quand on est
à onze heures aller retour par le train
ou neuf heures aller-retour par par la
route de la métropole régionale si ces
salles à la recherche de la proximité on
peut faire mieux
il ya manifestement un mépris d'un
certain nombre de territoires ruraux qui
est la caractéristique de ces décisions
je n'ose pas dire à caractère francilien
mais bon je suis l'heureux sujet des
régions comme les élections régionales
en décembre qui sont redoutés par le
pouvoir qui n'a depuis depuis de 2012
qui ne subit que dès que des échecs
vous craignez un nouveau un nouvel effet
qu un nouvel effet de balancier avec une
percée du front national
ce qui ce qui se passe depuis deux ans
est l'illustration de conséquences de
certains choix qui ne nous ont pas paru
à nos opportun nous l'avons dit sur les
institutions sur la réforme territoriale
il y a manifestement aussi des systèmes
électoraux qui favorise l'expression des
populismes
c'est faire voter nos concitoyens sur
les élections européennes dans des
circonscriptions qui n'ont aucun sens
ce qui fait qu ensuite il ne voit jamais
un député européen sur le terrain qu'il
n'y a jamais un débat dans nos
départements sur les programmes
européens qu'on les voit une fois quand
ils sont en campagne électorale et plus
ensuite
et ce qui va se passer pour les
régionales c'est un peu la même chose
nous allons avoir des candidats choisis
par les parties et qui sont ses fiefs la
plate hausse mais quand même ce sera
long
vous savez les conseillers régionaux et
le scrutin malheureusement n'a pas été
changées sur nos territoires presque
personne ne les connaît voilà la réalité
on connaît les maires on connaît les
présidents d'intercommunalités on
connaît les députés les sénateurs on
connaît pas les conseillers régionaux
donc il faut pas s'étonner ensuite que
ça donne
les gens connaissent sûrement le
président de religion où il compte celui
qui va être tête de l'isaf et vous
espérez encore vous une tête de liste
aux régionales comme radical de gauche
apparemment en midi pyrénées languedoc
roussillon s'est plié ce sera ce ne sera
pas si dia ping pour moi madame belga
pour moi ce n'est pas un espoir c'est
une nécessité
on ne peut pas considérer quand nous
avons des ministres au gouvernement sur
la loi macron et sur d'autres textes moi
je vote le budget considère que
l'opposition n'a pas tellement présenté
deux de meilleures solutions au niveau
budgétaire et financier nous sommes pas
d'accord sur un certain nombre de textes
mais considéré que le seul allié le seul
allié du gouvernement du parti
socialistes et radicaux de gauche et
bien sont marginalisés par le parti
socialiste ce n'est pas acceptable
ce n'est pas que c'est parce que vous
allez faire parce que là vous n'avez pas
de têtes de liste et fier coûté il est
possible tout à fait possible qu'il y
ait une liste radicale de gauche en
midi-pyrénées languedoc-roussillon si
aucun accord n'est possible
c'est tout bon je crois qu'il faut dire
les choses très clairement que madame
pinel qui est très gouvernement pour
prendre sa propre tête de liste elle
alors il
il peut écouter madame pinel ministre
madame delga est certainement quelqu'un
de très respectables mais je crois que
il n'y avait pas de raison que sylvia
pinel eux s'inclinent donc ce sont ce
sont des discussions entre les deux
parties moi je
ne participe pas à ces discussions je
considère effectivement qu'il faut
savoir ce que le parti socialiste veut
s'il ne veut avoir
s'il veut avoir son hégémonie il ne veut
s'il le veut avoir que des supplétifs
livre à lui moi je mène en tout cas
comme président de groupe au sénat une
politique de liberté en étant clair sur
les choix que le rds ce fait il n'y a
pas que des radicaux dans le même bien
mal récompensée où je ne cherche aucune
récompense clusaz il assume
ils assument leur comportement par
rapport à tous leurs alliés c'est qui
fait que en se conduisant de cette
manière eh bien ils fine et il se
retrouve petit à petit tout seul
à suivre donc notamment dans la région
midi pyrénées languedoc roussillon
merci jean louis perin ternaux arrive
maintenant pour aborder d'autres sujets
dont certains sont au coeur je le disais
tout à l'heure dès l'engagement des
radicaux la laïcité quand un calme et
menus des cantines scolaires crèches au
sein d'une administration publique ou
encore ramadan fêté par la mairie de
paris
à intervalles réguliers des
questionnements autour de la laïcité
reviennent au coeur du débat politique
dernière initiative au parlement sur le
sujet un texte des radicaux de gauche
après la sphère de la crèche baby loup
une loi adoptée mais aux effets minimes
elle impose la neutralité religieuse
dans les crèches privées des retouches
de la loi de 1905 auquel l'observatoire
de la laïcité n'était pas favorable
il y avait un problème puisque la cette
production doit imposer une totale
neutralité absolue le général pour tous
pour toute personne travaillant non
c'est dans ces structures c'est à dire
qu'il faut appliquer et faire respecter
la laïcité tout court sans adjectif et
c'est la laïcité telle qu'elle a été
définie par les pères fondateurs dans
tous les partis politiques de gauche le
débat est relancé notamment depuis les
attentats de janvier à paris dernier
exemple en date la proposition de
bernard cazeneuve de former des imams au
sein d'un cursus universitaire une idée
finalement abandonnée lors du dernier
congrès socialiste pour l'ancien
secrétaire national à la laïcité du
parti socialiste il y à bien une
défaillance de nombre d'élus sur le
sujet le parti socialiste et la gauche
en général
n'a pas réussi à créer un discours
solide a créé un discours alternatif
pour se positionner de façon claire de
façon républicaine sur la question de la
laïcité et aujourd'hui il ya une espèce
de deal un peu malsain entre certains
élus locaux et les communautarismes
religieux pour
non plus faire ce travail laïque mais
échanges et politiquement
des petits services entre amis autre
reproche adressé aux politiques par la
ligue des droits de l'homme la laïcité
est souvent instrumentalisée par le
personnel politique pour discriminer
davantage que pour inclure pour une
organisation de défense des droits de
l'homme l'instrumentalisation de la
laïcité comme moyen de débat politique
non pas sur des questions de principes
de la république
mais comme une espèce de d'armes
utilisées pour dénoncer l'autre pour le
discriminé c'est quelque chose de
gravissime enjeu des prochains mois
éclaircir la position de chacun sur le
sujet car un parti est en embuscade sur
ce thème
le front national voilà sur ces
questions perrine tarneaud bonsoir
désolé est ce que vous estimez jacques
mézard qu'aujourd'hui la laïcité est en
danger oui bien sûr et notamment remise
en cause par certains partis politiques
on voit que certains c'est du gauche une
certaine dérive auto la laïcité
bien sûr je disais tout à l'heure qu'il
y avait des lignes de fracture
fondamental à l'intérieur des grands
partis sur ce sujet là nous n'avons pas
de fracture chez nous car nous peut dire
nous sommes le parti de la laïcité c'est
un élément fondateur de notre vie
politique de tout ce que nous avons fait
depuis que nous existons et ce qui me
fait mal moi qui suis profondément
laïque c'est de voir reprendre l'idée de
la laïcité par les extrêmes ça c'est ces
deux aussi en partie de notre
responsabilité est ce que les grands
partis politiques français l'ont
abandonné notre parti socialiste tout à
fait mais nous aussi nous n'avons pas
été suffisamment fort nous ne sommes pas
suffisamment fait entendre depuis des
années alors que nous nous avons la
conviction que la laïcité à la française
est quelque chose d'essentiel et encore
plus aujourd'hui et que le principe en
est simple 1 c'est la religion c'est
dans la sphère privée et qu'elle n'a pas
à intervenir dans la sphère publique
est ce qu'il faut pour autant revoir la
loi de 1905 à la séparation entre
l'église et
non ce que beaucoup de voix un politique
aujourd'hui tout à fait mais là ce
serait une erreur fondamentale la loi de
on va pas refaire la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen c'est un
texte fondateur
y'a pas de raison qu'on refasse la loi
de 1905 qui a été un élément fort du
ciment national mais il ya quand même
des mères qui exprime un certain malaise
notamment dans le financement des cultes
pour financer par exemple la
construction de mosquées il ya des
maires des élus par exemple de banlieue
parisienne qui sont un petit peu obligé
de biaiser de construire des salles
polyvalentes qui ensuite deviennent des
lieux de culte que vous l'aurez qu'est
ce que vous leur répondez comment les
aider mais écoutez il ya des principes
et bien si je moi je suis de ceux qui
considèrent que les communes n'ont pas à
financer des lieux de culte et en même
temps dit qu'il faut contrôler le
financement des imams des mosquées mais
ça c'est l'argument numéro un pour dire
merci et vive voix la cicad
oui mais enfin c'est l'argument numéro
un et si on lâche là dessus eh bien on
lâchera surtout dire bear jeu je vais
moi maire d'une commune financer la
construction d'une mosquée ou d'un
temple ou de tout ce que tout ce que
l'on peut faire en matière religieuse
parce que si je ne le fais pas le qatar
le ferai écoutez on est dans un pays un
qui doit être ferme sur des règles qui
sont fondamentales parce que si on y
mission commence à y mettre les doigts
et moi je n'ai strictement rien contre
la religion musulmane c'est à dire que
c'est la multiplication alors la
revendication de revendication et pas
forcément simplement des musulmans il ya
un principe laïc il faut s'y tenir mois
que chacun que chacun puisse exercer
leur religion qu'il veut dans la plus
totale liberté
c'est parfait mais dans la sphère privée
on avait un socialiste dans le sujet là
qui parlait déjà de petits arrangements
entre amis
concrètement il pensait à quoi je vais
vers certains élus 7 face aux poussées
communautariste
je comprends que dans certaines communes
dans certaines communes où le poids
électoral
certaines communautés et fort il y à des
élus qui ont tendance à ne pas résister
à c'est une set c'est évident mais je ne
prends pas que ce soit une bonne chose
quand on est par exemple à la nuit du
ramadan quand on évoqua l'instant à
paris à l'hôtel de ville
je ne peux pas vous dire que je trouve
que la nuit du ramadan à paris soit une
bonne idée
elle doit elle devrait renoncer à cet
événement qui est organisé plusieurs
années l'hidalgo vous me posez la
question je considère que ce n'est pas
une bonne chose
bon alors ensuite je n'ai pas à juger du
côté électoralistes ou non et
électoralistes moi je me situe au niveau
des principes
parce que ce sera sans fin dans le dans
le xiiie arrondissement
nous avons beaucoup de nos concitoyens
qui sont d'origine chinoise alors on va
prendre leurs traditions il faut pas les
empêcher de respecter leurs propres
traditions mais là le public
la collectivité n'a pas à intervenir là
dedans votre réaction à l'appel lancé
par denis tillinac touche pas à mon
église contre la transformation des
églises en mosquée c'est peut-être le
cas dans le cantal
peut-être que vous avez des exemples
dans le cantal non non je désinfecte et
il y en a évidemment j'ai l'habitude de
ne signer aucune pétition
donc je comprends et je crois qu'il ne
faut pas provoquer nos concitoyens il y
a un attachement tout à fait clair de
chez nombre de nos concitoyens à des
traditions les églises dont quand même
un fond comme on dit un de pays chrétien
mais ce soit elles sont désertés par les
français écoutez je crois que je crois
qu'il faut être réaliste c'est quelque
chose qui sera très mal vécu 6 6 dans un
secteur la communauté catholique par
exemple considère que c'est une bonne
chose
ça peut se faire mais le faire de
manière provocatrice
il ne faut provoquer personne ni les
catholiques ni les musulmans ni les
protestants et vous disent il faut les
respecter et quand on prend des mesures
qui sont de nature justement à les
provoquer ce n'est pas une bonne chose
un rapport rendu hier au sénat d'une
commission d' enquête sur l'école et les
valeurs républicaines qui t a notamment
présidé par une sénatrice radicale
françoise laborde une vingtaine de
propositions qui vont du rapt
rétablissement de l'uniforme à l'école à
la suppression des allocations en cas
d'absentéisme au brouillage des
téléphones à la suppression des
tablettes c'est un peu troisième
république non tous à m'écouter et
qu'avez vous contre la troisième à
munich
elle a beaucoup fait pour la france elle
a amené beaucoup sur le territoire
national elle a amené l'école partout
elle a amené le train partout elle a
amené le téléphone partout et si toutes
les républiques était aussi efficace que
la troisième république l'a été ça se
saurait donc pourquoi ces mesures
peuvent redonner le sens des valeurs
républicaines dans ces mesures dans ces
mesures j'ai lu les vingt mesures
je ne les partage pas tout le fait de
créer des rires et des maisons
spécialisées pour ceux qui remue trop ne
paraît pas être une idée géniale mais
globalement ce sont essentiellement des
mesures de bon sens ce sont des mesures
visant à restaurer l'école la laïcité
l'idée de la république à l'école il n'y
a pas grand chose là dedans je vous le
dis je le dis que qui me choque il ya eu
c'est nier les valeurs républicaines
bien sûr bien sûr c'est à l'école
d'enseigner les valeurs républicaines
bien sûr que c'est à l'école de faire ce
qu'on appelait l'éducation civique et si
l'école où ils feront que l'école
d'abord elle doit apprendre à lire à
écrire français les mathématiques
l'histoire c'est pas tout je sais pas
toujours le cas aujourd'hui
et puis elle doit être l'école de la
république c'est en tout cas la vision
qui est la nôtre depuis que nous
existons
depuis y effectivement la troisième
république à dire qu'il ya un consensus
à ce que vous dites là écoutez je je
crois qu'il y à un large consensus si
long feu si l'on consulté nos
concitoyens sur ces vingt mesures il y
en aurait peut-être une ou deux ou trois
qui poserait problème est très largement
ça correspond aujourd'hui à un sentiment
république et qu'il soit porté par un
rapporteur ump avec une présidente de
commission aura nicole moi ça ne me
choque pas au contraire on entend
beaucoup jacques mézard actuellement
notamment dans la bouche de l'exécutif
et dans celle de françois hollande que
la procédure parlementaire est trop
lente
ça va pas assez vite est ce que vous
êtes d'accord si ça va pas assez vite le
premier responsable en et l'exécutif
parce que à force d'accumuler les
projets de loi pour montrer qu'on essaie
de tout réformer parce qu'avant c'etait
pas c'est bien que ça sera mieux demain
si l'exécutif le président de la
république pour unistar était de nous
envoyer des projets de loi qui sont
épais plusieurs dizaines de pages avec
des centaines d'articles la loi
maquereau en est un exemple la
transition énergétique en est un exemple
la loi santé en est un exemple
la réforme territoriale en est un
exemple moi je veux les textes des
gouvernements qui sont mal tu as fait et
cause tout à fait parce que une bonne
loi c'est une loi courte ce n'est pas
une loi bavarde
évidemment quand vous apporter 200
articles et courageuse des amendements
au c est bien mais bien sûr qu'on
rallonge la sauce c'est naturel quand
vous avez 200 articles vous discutez
c'est automatique vous présenter des
amendements sur ses articles si on nous
apporte un texte de loi où il ya un deux
trois articles vous verrez qu'il y aura
moins d'amendements le nous sommes dans
un système qui est à bout de course par
rapport à ça mais la responsabilité de
la durée de la loi elle elle incombe
d'abord à l'exécutif à bout de course ça
veut dire qu'il va y avoir des réformes
institutionnelles alors est ce que vous
craignez que sous cette petite musique
ambiante un de procédures parlementaires
trop lente c'est le bicamérisme qu'ils
pourraient être visés
menacée nous savons bien nous avons
entendu les propos du président de
l'assemblée nationale monsieur bartolone
il n'aime pas le sénat il veut le
supprimer c'est d'ailleurs dans good
outre il a bientôt quitter l'assemblée
pour faire campagne
et oui il était il était à fond pour le
non cumul donc il nous démontre en étant
à la fois président de l'assemblée
nationale et candidat pour être
président de région que entre le
discours et l'action pour un certain
nombre des responsables politiques il ya
une grande nuance oui françois hollande
pourrait convoquer un congrès en 2016
début 2016 pour notamment faire ratifier
la charte sur les langues régionales est
ce que vous voterez pour le texte arrive
au sénat à l'automne
pratique personnelle non et c'est pas la
position de votre groupe
côté livres chacun est libre c'est une
caractéristique
ça veut dire que si vous déjà vous voté
contre y perd des voix à gauche et donc
il y aura du mal à avoir une majorité m
c'est une position précaire ce parce que
vous êtes contre d'aidé et que l'on
valorise les langues régionales au
détriment
je crois qu chose en a appelé mini-cités
la république la langue nationale
oui je je je le concède - qui est qu'on
puisse enseigner des langues régionales
qu'il y ait des moyens apportés par
certaines collectivités 1 pour les
langues régionales ça ne me choque pas
mais aujourd'hui où on voit que
l'apprentissage de la langue
l'apprentissage du français pose
tellement de problèmes
est ce que c'est vraiment aujourd'hui
qu'il faut se lancer là dedans je ne
crois pas donc vous nous conseillez
d'affaires de congrès là dessus ils me
demandent rarement conseille même jamais
je ne me permettrais jamais eu tout du
tout ils pourront consulter quand même
les radicaux de gauche
je ne doute pas qu'il consulte le
président du parti radical de gauche
mais je suis le président du rds s'est
dit fier merci jacques mézard d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui il faut aussi
mais rien avec vous soigner
noël j court très vite on sera tous
ouah